la gauche espérait reprendre ce canton
de trappes ce premier tour confirme cet
espoir le duo divers-gauche alliera b et
anne marie a booké arrive en tête ce
dimanche soir avec 39 28 % des suffrages
le binôme qui a réalisé plus de 60% des
voix sur la ville de trappes est en
position favorable pour refaire basculer
ce bastion historique de la gauche pris
par la droite en 2015 des forces
considérables se sont rassemblés autour
des candidats de la droite et pourtant
nous les avons battus au premier tour
donc nous avons les moyens de les battre
également au second tour pour cela il
faut compter sur la mobilisation de ceux
qui croient que un seul parti politique
ne peut pas diriger à lui seul un
département comme divine les candidats
de la gauche affronteront au 2e tour le
binôme sortant nicolas dainville and
capio le duo a réalisé 36 97 % des
suffrages
on est plutôt content du résultat
on a encore la semaine prochaine pour
mobiliser sur l'ensemble du canton à peu
près 200 à 250 voix pour pouvoir pour
pouvoir ravir cette élection
à mon avis a pas de y'a pas de soucis on
est on y croit et on va y arriver il n'y
a pas de ya pas de problème
les autres candidats sont loin derrière
en troisième position on retrouve le duo
du rassemblement national nelly billard
et christophe gensac dix 60% des
suffrages comme en 2015 le rn et
troisième sur le canton on est entre
guillemets nos tasses sur la
circonscription de frappe souvent
troisième position avec on n'arrive pas
à faire bouger les lignes s'avéra
derrière en quatrième position le duo
lrm ne dépasse pas les 10 % sur le
canton de trappes
c'est un score qui reste décevant mais
néanmoins honorable selon un canton où
on présente pour la première fois une
équipe
donc nous avons essayé de
de convaincre de séduire sur un projet
qui est effectivement ni de gauche ni de
droite
enfin robert un haga retina mais
emmanuel ray man termine avec 2 60%
devant gwladys lui sert et hocine toi tu
y es avec 0 90% le canton letra peut-il
être repris par la gauche réponse au
prochain tour ce dimanche 27 juin